[Music]
to quote another dead friend of mine
Cardinal Manning great great thinker he
said a counter I know you really just
need a little bug in the corner it
Colonel Manning had this line he said at
bottom all human conflict is theological
and this I notice is something that
keeps coming up as you as you're talking
which is the secular issue there's
nothing to lean on there's nothing to
believe in there's enough no objective
reality so and you mentioned Douglas
Murray you're very much alive friend
he's alive he's British it's weird to me
I don't know a living British thinker
those three don't go together very
exciting so he has this line yeah which
maybe you would fall into too is that he
says he's a Christian atheist direct
cultural Christian or something like
that yeah basically saying a
Christianity is good it shaped the West
we need it but I myself cannot believe
yeah well Douglas also happens to be gay
yeah that's right it is it is just a
part of him it is not the sum of who he
is you know I I hate until you said that
I had forgotten it's kind of like with
you I sometimes forget because you don't
make it the centerpiece of your identity
you're not gonna believe this knows I'm
not constantly thinking about your
sexuality either why not you know
thinking it's a lot to be thinking you
know I'd be insulted on my show today
you have your nice solid thank you but I
think there is look Douglas I don't know
I've interviewed Douglas a million times
we were very good friends I don't know
of a position that Douglas holds that is
different than my book right i I've yet
to find one now Douglas in a in a
British sense
he calls himself a conservative yeah
which you know again without getting
lost than that thing it's basically what
an old-school liberal is I have no
problem if that's what conservatism is
and if acknowledging as Douglas is doing
in that idea acknowledging that
judeo-christian values and as Ben talks
about the the balance between Jerusalem
and and Athens
if acknowledging all of that is what
makes the world go yeah is what gives us
the underpinning to free people well
then I'm a conservative and that
but but do you do you think like is it
enough to acknowledge as I think it's
like every sensible person I know today
does as you do as Jordan Pederson does
that you need religion and you need like
a good religious society cannot organize
around anything else it needs religion
plea cannot do it that doesn't mean that
there aren't people individual people
yeah
sam harris for example i believe him to
be a deeply moral person he's a good
buddy of mine weed yeah I don't many
times you know like I don't know if you
would want that he we've had drinks many
times just drink I don't know that I'm
totally a guy Branum I'll just say I ha
ha um but but Michael Shermer Peter
Burgos Ian I know plenty of atheists who
are good moral decent people those ideas
cannot organize societies they simply
cannot the idea that you can mindfully
meditate yeah the way to a good society
simply does not work and that aside that
by the way is is why Jordan Peterson
exploded the way he did yeah and that
also by the way with Jordan being mi a
right now is why it feels like there's a
hole in the internet doesn't it it does
because Jordan not only did he show
people that that personal responsibility
clean your room is important but he also
said to bury something outside of you
know there is some driving force outside
of you that has been churned through the
generations I believe there is there the
scientists and the philosophers and the
atheists and all these people they can
come up with all the good stuff they
want they can meditate and they can
think that cannot it offers no defense
when the barbarians are at the gate and
that's why every liberal institution is
being destroyed what is being destroyed
right now Harvard academia oh yeah the
New York Times is every day the New York
Times it's like the New York Times is
really in a core implosion right now you
know how when there's a core implosion
like when I'm when like a big Star Wars
or a planet it is like an imploding it
like takes a little while and then it
caught the first bit yeah I'm sure
there's a scientific principle of that
like you know there's a while where it's
like getting hotter and hotter and
hotter and then it crosses that Rubicon
and then and then just the New York
Times every day wow you guys are like we
all saw it but now this is just beyond
bananas but it is going to eat out this
took a turn el down here sorry yeah
we don't have a shelter yeah it is going
to dismantle and destroy every liberal
institution and the only things that
will exist after will have been the
things that inoculated themselves from
social justice and that will be a couple
conservative institutions once you let
just yesterday on slow well stuff just
yesterday on Twitter did you see this
thing some guy his wife or his
girlfriend is applying for a job at
Twitter and she he said she's a lefty
but she screenshot where they wanted to
know to be hired by Twitter your gender
identity and one was like I'm
cisgendered heteronormative I'm I'm a
giraffe yeah joy like it was like the
eight things and and you look at them
and no sensible person can make any
sense out of them yeah but even putting
at that aside once you let social
justice in that these things matter yeah
if you're working at Twitter I want you
to be a good coder when I hire people I
have a small business I don't care what
gender identity you are I don't care
what color you are small business that's
doing very well by the way locals calm
locals calm and and my production
company they're both doing great we have
zero debt we're growing and guess what
it's because I hire you're not gonna
believe this Knowles I hire qualified
people not people based on their gender
identity so you're a felon is what
you're saying I'm sure now well even in
California right now what are they
trying to do what's our local LA
assembly trying to do right now they
want the equal protections to be drankin
out because they write discrimination to
be encoded in our law
[Music]
you
[Music]